Abbas Khan was just a few days from
freedom when he was found dead he loved
his family deeply and he was devoted to
helping others and it's kind of
something that flippantly everyone says
but that really drove him the father of
two from South London had spent a year
in Syrian jails in letters home the 32
year old orthopedic surgeon had written
that he'd been tortured his family
feared for his mental health but they
say that changed when the Syrian
authorities revealed the decision to
free him have come from the highest
levels a statement taken to mean
President Assad himself
I'd like to dispel any sort of concepts
of of suicide straight away this is a
letter from him just a couple of days
ago in good spirits optimistic about his
release saying that he thought he'd been
granted amnesty already and he was
looking forward to being home for
Christmas dr. Karl had gone to Syria
because he wanted to use his medical
skills to help people caught up in the
civil war he was arrested at a
checkpoint in the city of Aleppo in
November 2012 in one letter home he
wrote my retention which is approaching
one year has included repeated and
severe beatings largely for no reason in
addition to this I have been violently
forced to beat other prisoners kept in
squalid conditions denied access to
toilets or medical treatment in a letter
to Foreign Secretary William Hague one
of dr. Cowan's children had written
please help our dad to come home because
we miss him too much and we cry every
day I have not seen Baba for a year and
I want to hug him Syria's Deputy Foreign
Minister Faisal mcdhh ad said dr. Khan
had been found by guards hanged at his
cell and appeared to have committed
suicide the Foreign Office is far from
convinced and wants an explanation the
fact remains that he went to Syria to
help the people of Syria who were
affected by the Civil War there is no
excuse whatsoever for the treatment that
he has
by the Syrian authorities who have in
effect murdered a British national was
in their country to help people injured
during the Civil War
so the Syrians insist dr. Kahn's death
was suicide his family says
categorically not an independent
investigation will be almost impossible
until the war is over to muscle Sky News